When I Google search ORM for
Python I get over 14
million results with several
different ORM options we could use.
The first result that showed
up when I searched was for
an application called SQL Alchemy.
SQL Alchemy is an open source ORM for
Python with a slew of features.
Not to mention this awesome
Getting Started tutorial.
There's a lot of
information on this page.
But let's just focus on setting up
our database and tables for now.
If you're using the Vagrantfile,
SQLAlchemy is already installed
on your virtual machine.
If you are not using Vagrant,
you can install SQLAlchemy from
the link below to follow along.